a va t elle être maintenue mais roi de
tous les maestros 20000 euros 0
[Musique]
on veut bien
je comblerai lacunes de thézan li na ou
et j'ai bloc ces barrages 20 millions
11,0
[Applaudissements]
446 1000 euros encore à mille euros
gagnés vous bloque ses paroles
quatre cent soixante six mille euros on
n'a pas spécialement nous envie que vous
perdiez gepan hommes sentiment non plus
que le public a envie que vous perdiez
j'ai le sentiment que les chaînes
concurrentes ont envie que vous perdiez
et que la direction de france 2 envie
que vous gagnez un peu moins mais c'est
comme ça et aller à 500000 est allé à un
million et tout va bien tout va bien
mais c'est d'olive est bel et bien passé
là et 500 millions d'euros
pour connaître des gens sont nés les
téléspectateurs des 4 millions ça a
démarré avec tout le monde veut prendre
sa place ya quelques années où il
s'amusait à faire revenir des candidats
pour faire monter l'audience au mois de
mai rhône négocier les contrats
puis après ils ont fait la même chose
sur tf1 les 12 coups de midi et
maintenant ils font ça tout au long de
l'année donc c'est formidable parce que
sa part et de fidéliser téléspectateurs
mais forcément les formalités ont
demandé d'argent
comment il ya aussi des gens qui pensent
que c'est ce qu'on aime donner autant
d'argent public elle le mérite et oser
pas au départ quand n'oubliez pas les
paroles vous le savez bien on va pas en
parler mais vous aviez aussi n'oubliez
pas les paroles entre les mains le prêt
mais il faut vraiment que je me pende
dans les normes
le rappeler que j'ai raté ma vie à dix
ans
j'ai coincé à sa guise et encore je veux
juste vous expliquer un truc c'est la
première fois qu'on faisait un jeu sur
le service public on pouvait gagner cent
mille euros et à l'époque patrice
duhamel miley mais attendez c'est pas
une émission extrêmement intelligente
sur le service public c'est un peu
compliqué mais moi je m'étais réfugié
sur le patrimoine de la chanson
française puisque tout le monde parle du
manque de chanson française à la
télévision en fait je peux vous dire que
c'est une émission qui s'est répandu
quotas il amène en même pas un accord
juste non non non ça va pas durer on
sait quand ça va vous n'avez pas spolier
madame le spoil et merci c'est bientôt
l'heure mais la soupe mais juste un mot
quand même sur cette émission dont toute
hâte d'être non non aux non bacheliers
une émission à faire notamment parlé
d'un problème
les gens se plaignent des prestations
vocales de margaux qui ne chante pas
très bien oui le moins que l'on puisse
dire regardez
[Musique]
c
entier
[Musique]
tous
c'est un fait
[Musique]
et
m
dans les yeux je suis et le feu
lander
[Applaudissements]
elle serait bien chanter les gens se
plaindre ex et un casting de
professionnels a bien joué on a rigolé
heureusement qu'elle sait pas chanter
ses mérites en temps réel à la paix 16
750 chanson elle regarde l'émission
depuis qu'elle est toute jeune et avait
entendu avec l'air ce serait là on
connaît tous ses chansons par coeur sans
salaire ou à moi j'ai pas gagné non sait
jamais un parc chanté toute l'essence
était éliminé d'académie oui c'est
l'époque on lit que la sentais pas très
bien très bien moi pour moi c'est un
carnage est une blessure profonde c'est
une plaie béante qu'on réouvre déjà pas
non plus ah bah si c'est tout à fait ça
mais simplement terminer moi quand je
regarde cette émission c'est terrible
pour moi c'est le camping de palavas les
flots
le repenti à une secte de gens qui
dansent derrière c'est fou ces mecs là
comme ça tous la même chorégraphie une
nana qui tue fait un carnage c'est un
carnage tous les soirs alors super elle
connaît les chansons par coeur et moi et
toutes mes copines on connaît toutes les
chansons on va demander un ami nagui 6,6
et tu nous regardes c'est ton émission
c'est ainsi qu'il est bon voilà la
nation qu'elle a besoin de 500 mille
euros 6 mais voilà qu'est ce qui est le
thème de l'émission c'est pas je sais
chanter l'émission c'est justement de
n'oubliez pas les paroles ça veut dire
que si la fille en talents de tout
retenir est tout savoir elle a sa place
comme alex et moi je suis fan en plus de
sa personnalité la trouve drôle parce
qu'elle en a rien à [ __ ] d'être
ridicule au contraire elle s'assume
complètement
c'est vrai que
aghali je ne suis pas souvent d'accord
avec magali mais là comme on dit comme
on dit dans le midi
vous parlez d'or va racheter des
missions votre show benjamin et elle
favorisé il faut rappeler que la
production a fait une très grosse erreur
il ya quelques semaines où ça l'a
vraiment mise en jambe en danger par
bonds sur le programme donc s'il a la
preuve vraiment la favoriser il aurait
peut-être récupérer cette erreur c'était
c'est quoi la grosse erreur par rapport
à son adversaire
à un moment c'était la finale dans le
jeu où les pas la mauvaise parole
s'étaient inscrites elles auraient dû
être éliminés normalement mais du coup
la production c'est comme ça à laquelle
ils ont fait un petit arrangement avec
la vérité on va dire ouais voilà il
aurait pu aussi la joue